- Trans women in
biological women's sports.
I honestly think it's
a case by case basis...
- Why do you think that
it should be a case
by case basis, because I don't think
that they should be allowed
in women's sports at all.
- If you had to rank
yourself against others based
on a specific trait, what
would it say about how
you see them and how they see you?
To find out,
we brought together five
conservatives and had
them rank each other least
to most politically right.
Then we had them take the
political compass test
and rearrange them based on
how right they actually are.
This is ranking.
- I'm Hunter.
I do security for a living.
I believe in Jesus.
I don't really go to church,
but that's how I was brought up.
I'm also a little bit more
libertarian than I am authoritarian.
So smaller government, if any.
- I'm Cameron, I am not religious at all.
I am agnostic.
I was in the Marine Corps for four years.
I am very, very pro-gun.
I believe it is my equalizer.
I will never be as strong
as a stronger male,
but I definitely have my right
to my second amendment and
we'll use it if need be.
- My name is Navi.
You can also call me Navi,
like from legend of Zelda.
When, when it comes to my
political views, I describe myself
as fiscally conservative, but
socially I follow more of a
like a paleo libertarian, like,
you know, school of thought.
So I would describe myself as
a very like constitutionalist.
I very much so support the first amendment
the second amendment, but
I'd be considered more
like left leaning on some other topics
such as like, I'm an environmentalist.
I very much so support
the GT com L G T community
because a lot of my
friends are part of it.
I'm part of it.
To be more specific I'm bisexual.
Yeah, and that's also by the way
the first time I'm saying that publicly.
- Oh, well congratulations.
- My name is Kelly.
I am from New York,
living in Washington, DC.
I am religious, I'm Jewish.
I don't support the
L.G.B.T. community at all.
I'm not anti gay or anything,
but I do support traditional
values in the home.
However, I don't 100 percent
believe that my religious values
have anything to do with
my conservative values.
I try to keep religion out
of the way, because I know
that there are conservatives
who are not religious.
I'm Maui.
I'm originally from Colorado.
I'm kind of like in a
weird spot where I grew
up religious and I grew up very liberal.
I've been back and forth a lot
of topics as far as immigration,
because I'm half Mexican.
It's strange because coming
from like a traditional Mexican family
they hold a lot of conservative values
but they very much label
themselves as liberal.
- A lot of black people that I know
and grew up with have
like conservative values.
But like, if you ask them like, you know
who are you gonna vote for?
It's always going to be
Democratic no matter what.
So I find that really interesting
that you said that because
I have like a connection with that.
- What do you think are
like traditional traditions
that conservatives hold?
- Liking guns.
I mean painting with a broad brush,
it's common sense things.
I think support constitution.
Like I, I agree with all the amendments
- Just the general idea though.
Like you should be able to pick yourself
up by the bootstraps.
And if you put in the
hard work, you can get
to where you want to be
the beauty of this country
no matter who you are.
Obviously some people have
certain factors that will like,
you know, make it easier
or like harder for them.
But I feel like in this country
with the amount of
opportunity that we have
you can be anyone and get
to where you want to be.
- This is an interesting question.
I think, I don't think being
conservative has anything to do
with your political affiliation.
I think those things are separate.
And I think a lot of
people confuse the two.
We just talked about
how the black community
the Indian community makes the community.
They're all, some of them
a lot of them are conservatives,
but they're left leaning.
- I really do believe like
I don't care what you do
in your life.
You're a grown adult.
You have no effect on me.
I'm not religious.
Like don't force your
religion down my throat.
Don't force your opinions down my throat.
We can have a discussion.
I'm very open to having
dialogues with anyone.
I love to have conversation
like something that's going
on right now is like the whole trans woman
in biological women's sports.
I honestly think it's
a case by case basis.
- Why do you think that it's a...
It should be a case by case
basis because I don't think
that they should be allowed
in women's sports at all.
- I agree with you on that, it
should be not case per case.
It just wouldn't be allowed.
Because when we've seen it,
I don't know, statistics off hand,
but people just dominate
that are biologically men.
- I feel like dealing with like
absolutes in a general sense
like in the political
discourse can be a very
dangerous thing.
Because as he mentioned, there
are outliers and we always
have to, you know, factor those in.
So I'm not, I'm not sure I agree
with that, but yeah, I can
see where you're coming from.
- I think my difference is I don't think
that trans women are biological woman.
I'm not gonna be a dick.
if you want me to refer to
you as she, her I'll do that.
I'll call you by your name.
I'm gonna give you that
respect as a human being.
- It's okay.
To be different.
- Yeah.
- I don't understand what you guys mean
by outliers because they're all men.
So what do you mean?
I see this as absolute.
Trans women are not women, they're men.
- I mean, I would never like
call it ignorance or something.
It's just, everyone has their own views.
I can completely understand that.
- Should we vote like democratically?
- I mean, I'm gonna say
you're probably a five for me.
Not a, not a bad thing.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And it's not a bad thing.
- One is the most, five is the least.
- I put you over there.
- I put you there.
- Me over here?
- Yeah.
- I was thinking you number three.
And you number two, I felt like...
- Is it because of the religion?
- Yes.
- I think there are like two schools
of thought we can go with here.
We can either go with like
traditional conservative values
which one of us like upholds
it most, which I feel
like you would still be the
most, like when it comes
to like the traditional
values you've described
or we can go by like policy
wise, whether, you know
each one of us falls in line
and I like maybe don't
support every single, you know
policy of like the Republican party
or just general conservative positions.
So we could go in either direction.
- I was like, I think you'd
be over here just because like
when I think of like
and I don't mean like
a typical conservative
but when I think of a conservative
I think upholds, like
religion, traditional values.
- I can go three.
That, that sounds good.
Okay.
- We're all pro-gun right.
And pro speech and everything.
Okay, so we're, we're on the
same page as it comes to that,
then we can just go into
other like, I guess policies.
- Well, how do you feel
on like an abortion topic?
- Well, abortion, I feel is dangerous.
Abortion's gonna happen if
it's got rid of, and there are,
I mean, I don't want to go
into a small percentage,
which it is, but there are,
are late term ones where
the mom will die.
And then there's also ones where if
if you make abortion legal,
like coat hangers are a thing,
it's sad, but it's true.
So what if we...
Don't count like the extreme cases?
Would you say mostly?
- I think keep life.
Yeah, unless it's going to harm a life,
like the mom or the baby.
If it's, if it's gonna come out
you can predict it's gonna be fine.
Then we should keep children alive, yes.
- I guess for me, I, like I said,
I've gone back and forth and
I don't want to be for it,
but currently I am for abortion.
I don't think anyone wants to be for it.
So it's not something that is
an easy thing to want to do.
- I believe birth control should be free.
I a hundred percent
support free birth control.
I think that it would be a...
It would've dramatically
decrease abortions.
But I am very much, we need
to fix the afterwards as well.
So the adoption agency, I
think we need to fix that.
And I think we need to advocate more
for younger women to know
about birth control options that we have.
- I kind of wanted to bring this up.
Is everyone kind of more like
an interventionist kind of
you know, thought process?
Or is it like, like kind
of like isolationist,
or even like in between,
like, do you think we should focus
on our country's problems first?
- Yes, absolutely.
- How are we gonna help
other countries when
we have so many other things?
- Yeah, so too much foreign spending.
- Yeah, so like just, we just
spent how, how much money
to Ukraine, why, that has
nothing to do with us.
That money could have went to America.
- If we're prioritizing that
we can't even like take care
of our own people.
Like veterans are like
starving on the street.
They're homeless.
I feel like we should
do something about that
but we can because we're focusing
on other countries instead
of our own people who need help.
Does anyone feel differently
about their position now?
- I don't know, I think we should switch.
I really focus on that
whole, like he holds more
traditional conservative values than I do.
I was like, just in that
sense, I would switch us.
- I think what it was for me,
was you seemed a lot more passionate
in that you were more outspoken,
a little bit more quieter,
so maybe you know what, you're number two.
But now that I'm hearing more opinions.
Yeah, I would probably agree
with switching you two.
- We're moving.
- What values does everyone have
that they feel like doesn't exactly fall
in line with the traditional
conservative value
or just generally conservative values?
- I'm against the wall
because I'm a libertarian.
Okay, I think most people coming here
aren't coming here to hurt people.
They're coming to make
money and make a living.
- I am actually for the wall, but not
because I want to keep
people out, strictly
because I want to know who's coming
into this country in a good sense.
Sex trafficking in general,
comes through our Southern border.
So do drugs.
So that's the only reason.
I don't care if people wanna
come here to immigrate,
be my guest.
- I'm 100% against illegal
immigration and that's not...
So I am for the wall, but
it's not just the wall.
It's the people who are coming here
and overstaying their visas.
They need to go too.
- My position is unique
because I immigrated for
Mexico when I was younger
and I wouldn't be here most
likely if it weren't for that.
But I do really believe
that illegal immigration
is just that, illegal.
- Now what I'm gonna have you
guys do is grab your phones
and go onto
thepoliticalcompass.org and take
the political compass test.
In the fifth spot, we have Maui.
And then fourth, we have Cameron.
- I thought I'd be more
like two three-ish area.
- And then we have
Kelly in the third spot.
- Interesting.
- In the second spot we have Navi.
And in first, Hunter.
- I didn't expect myself to
move up this much, right?
- Yeah.
- The way this like political
compass test is framed,
like it does evoke certain reactions.
So it's not entirely like encompassing
of like my views and everything, but yeah.
Are any of you guys surprised?
- I don't know.
I thought I was gonna be third
or second in all honesty.
I thought I was gonna be over here.
- Some of those questions,
like I never really thought about before.
- I kind of figured I'd
be somewhere over here
like four or five after
hearing everyone's opinions.
- I mean, I think it's weird
that I'm number one and I'm
a tall white, straight, male.
- Perfect, yeah.
- If anyone out there who's watching
this does not agree with like me or anyone
else's political views,
please just look at us as people.
Everyone has flaws.
And I just want people to see
that we can bridge that divide
by just being human to each other.
So just spread love everyone.
Just spread love.